she said I'm down with melanoma I'm
cured that'll live my life like I'm
Jarrod
I've had a friend and he died of this
stomach cancer my mother died when I was
about 10 years old of lymphoma and I was
the result and I thought what I can do
for this type of the diseases when I had
the chance to meet the first patient I
was split this was a life-changing
moment it really that's what at first
you know really became clear to me
exactly what was going on and I have a
friend who told me this is that my last
round in my life because I had a lung
cancer about maybe half a year or so
later he came back and I just started
the treatment you developed and he just
completely cured it was fantastic
sitting just a cancer therapy this is a
way of liberating people from you know
just a burden of having this disease
they could come back and kill you
I hope the century will be remembered
that the century of the cancer treatment
[Music]